Prof: Let me begin by
repeating my last point in last
Tuesday's lecture.
The birth of Don Quixote
is an act of self invention by a
man of fifty,
and remember that fifty is a
very advanced age in 1605.
He feels free to create himself
beyond family birth and need.
In this, the novel is directly
opposed to most previous
literature, particularly the
romances of chivalry where they
were miraculous births.
And the picaresque,
very much in particular,
the picaresque,
in which family background and
need determined the life of the
protagonist,
or so he claims as he tells his
life,
his poverty,
and the family background
weighs heavily on the rest of
his life in the case of the
pícaro.
Don Quixote is beyond family
and social determinisms.
In most previous stories,
young people leave home in
search of adventures that will
give substance,
meaning and individuality to
their lives.
Can you think of another old
protagonist before Don Quixote?
How old was the pilgrim in
the Divine Comedy?
I think he was thirty-three.
How old was Odysseus in the
Odyssey?
How old Aeneas in the
Aeneid?
Celestina, it is true,
was old, but she shares the
limelight with young lovers.
Don Quixote,
as I think I said in the last
class, is beyond Freud,
beyond the family romance.
In fact, though we learn a
great deal about him in the
first chapter,
we learn nothing of his
parents.
His genealogy is literary,
the books that he has read.
The most innovative aspect of
Don Quixote is the character's
self fashioning as Steve
Greenblatt would put it in a
book called Renaissance
Self-Fashioning.
The reader witnesses this self
transformation in all its
levels, from the mental to the
physical, from what Don Quixote
thinks to what he wears.
He, not an author,
names him, his horse and his
lady.
His is a life that will be
molded like a work to art.
Life will imitate art.
But what is the significance of
this self invention,
of this resurrection as it
were?
Renaissance humanism emphasized
the power of human agency.
It is the beginning of a
liberation from a God-centered
conception of the world and of
human kind.
Remember, the Lukács
quote about the Quixote
being the first story of a world
that has been abandoned by God.
So in this world abandoned by
God man creates himself,
Don Quixote creates himself.
"En un lugar de la
Mancha de cuyo
nombre..."
This is the first sentence of
the book.
Jarvis translates:
"In a village of La Mancha
the name of which I purposely
omit there lived long ago."
This is a sentence,
by the way, that most literate
native speakers of Spanish know
by heart even if they haven't
read the rest of the
Quixote.
And the disclaimer,
"de cuyo nombre no
quiero acordarme"
is also used in conversation,
to say I don't want to remember
this.
Now, it is known the way that
English speakers know,
"It was the best of
times," "it was the
worst of times,"
A Tale of Two Cities,
or, "Call me Ishmael,
"the beginning of Moby
Dick and so forth.
In the Quixote
literature appears,
as I've been saying,
as a realm of self legitimation
and the display of wit and
capacity for invention which is
what Cervantes appears to be
affirming in the first sentence
of the book.
He does not wish,
as a narrator,
he does not wish to remember
the place in La Mancha where Don
Quixote lived.
It is a display of authorial
will.
The sentence is full of other
implications;
there is the echo of the
opening of traditional stories
as well as that of official
documents that attest to one's
being by stating where one is
from in the stories,
"in such-and-such a
country long ago"
and the country is named.
Or "my name is such-and-so
and I live in such-and-such a
place, and was born in
such-and-such a place,"
a legal document.
To make such a statement is
one's strongest form of
grounding, but here willfully
omitted.
A place name that is erased by
the creative will of the author:
"No quiero
acordarme,"
I don't want to remember it,
against the traditional
formulas in which it is given.
The origin, this origin,
this place,
this village,
this lugar as it's
called in the sixteenth century
Spanish,
to which the protagonist
returns several times and
definitively at the end is not
named.
It is as if here the source
were non-determining,
as the age of Don Quixote is
non-determining in his
subsequent adventures.
This is perhaps the reason why
the origin,
which is also the
destination--because Don Quixote
will return to die at home
giving away the plot here,
I'm sorry--this is perhaps the
reason why the origin which is
also a destination is left blank
deliberately effaced from the
story.
It is a non-place,
although many towns in Spain
claim to be the town in which
Don Quixote was born.
Now, Don Quixote's name and
other names,
we have all ready spoken about
quesada,
quijada,
quejana,
and by now you have read all of
these potential variations of
Alonso Quijano's first name.
The point is also one prevalent
throughout the book,
the fluctuations of language in
reference to meaning and to
truth.
If language is so shifty,
how can we express the truth in
language?
Spitzer, Leo Spitzer,
a great German critic who
worked in this country for many
years and taught at Johns
Hopkins University,
in the piece "On
Linguistic Perspectivism"
that you will read in your
Casebook makes much of
this,
and he makes much of this with
the knowledge of the linguist
and philologist that he was,
you will see.
Language and its vagaries also
constitutes Cervantes's point of
view about what is commonly
accepted as the truth,
and how the truth can be
commonly accepted in a medium as
shifty as language.
But the blurry name,
Quixote, quijana,
quesada,
and so forth,
is also a way of playing with
the absence of determinisms as
being from La Mancha,
a non-place,
as it were, a name and a place
marked the characters in the
epic and in the romances of
chivalry,
and even the picaresque novels:
Amadís de Gaula,
of Gaul;
Lazarillo de Tormes,
Tormes is the river that goes
through Salamanca,
by the way, in which the
pícaro is supposed
to have been born;
Gúzman de Alfarache,
a place that is named,
Alfarache.
But not in the Quixote
significantly.
Now, Don Quixote names his lady
Dulcinea del Toboso and
Rocinante.
In the first case,
the lady, he follows literary
convention.
Her name rhymes with Melibea,
who is one of the protagonists
of Celestina,
the beautiful young woman.
And 'dulce' means
'sweet' in Spanish,
so you can see the origin and
the intention behind naming
Dulcinea that,
while the horse's name reflects
something of his reality,
'Rocinante,'
'rocín-ante,'
meaning he was a
'rocín,' a
workhorse,
before, 'antes' is
'before' in Spanish.
Rocinante, the name,
does reflect in a very direct
and comical way,
because it reflects precisely
the reality about this nag.
Don Quixote's capacity naming
for naming, as we will see,
is quite extraordinary,
he is a man words and of the
word.
But the crucial point here is
that he is naming himself,
his lady, and his horse as part
of this process of self
invention,
like Adam, giving names to
things in the Garden of Eden,
or God giving names to things.
This is part and parcel of the
process of self invention,
I repeat.
Now, we move on to chapter II
which is one of the most,
for me, remarkable moments in
all of literature.
The protagonist has created
himself and he leaves at dawn,
the beginning of a new day,
of a new life,
and sets out on the Montiel
Plain alone.
It is a will beginning from
zero, from a voluntary severing
of ties with any possible
determining force except for the
loss of chivalry and for
literature.
It is a moment of freedom,
of freedom achieved,
freedom from the past.
But as he goes along,
he anticipates,
Don Quixote anticipates the
literary text that will be
written about the exploits that
he is in the process of
accomplishing,
or that he thinks he's in the
process of accomplishing.
There's a gap,
of course, between the high
flown rhetoric of the romances
of chivalry that he uses and the
literal plain--
there is a plain--upon which he
gallops or trots probably.
But this is precisely the gap
between literature and reality,
between writing and experience
that will be at the core of
Cervantes' exploration of the
nature of writing.
The present and the writing of
the text hangs somewhere in
between the reality and this
high flown rhetoric that are
parallel and simultaneous in
their appearance in the book.
This is quite remarkable and it
may pass unnoticed,
but I want you to take notice
of it.
It's on the translation we are
using, pages 26,27,
Don Quixote,
as he goes on the plain of
Montiel says to himself:
"Who doubts but that but
in future times when the
faithful history of my famous
exploits are come to light,
the sage who writes them when
he gives a relation of this my
first sally so early in the
morning,
will do it in words like this:
'Scarcely had the ruddy feebles
spread the golden tresses of his
beauteous hair over the face of
the wide and spacious earth and
scarcely had the painted birds
with the sweet and mellifluous
harmony of their forked tongues
saluted the approach of rosy
Aurora who,
quitting the soft coach of her
jealous husband...'"-- and
so forth and so on.
He's using all of these
references to Classical
mythology to refer to himself as
he projects the text that will
be written about him.
Now, he arrives at the inn.
We know, and this is a fact to
remember, from the episode in
the inn, that Don Quixote leaves
home on a hot Friday in July.
How do we know this?
We know it because they serve
fish to Don Quixote at the inn,
explaining that the eating of
red meat is forbidden on Fridays
by the Catholic Church.
It was until the 1960s of the
past century.
So it is clear because it is a
hot day and it is the month of
July that this is a hot Friday
in July.
The specificity of time and
place is a new feature of
fiction, of this realist
fiction.
As we saw, the romances of
chivalry took place in vague
fabulous countries and times.
Not the Quixote, which
derived from the picaresque a
pension for the particular in
everything.
It is the birth of what we know
as realism,
whose origins and intention I
spoke about in the last lecture,
interest in society at its
lowest level and the acquisition
of aesthetic value by the
sordid, the ugly and the dirty.
Now, the heat by the way,
would presumably and it says so
in the text,
contribute to Don Quixote's
madness according to theories of
the time which are probably not
all together wrong--
if you are out in the desert in
the heat,
you might lose your senses, too.
But the weather is important
for other reasons in the
Quixote,
specific weather,
not the fabulous weather,
mists and all of that in the
romances of chivalry.
Both parts of the novel take
place in a vaguely framed
summer,
in part, because the heat
contributes to Don Quixote's
madness,
as I say, but also because it
makes it logical for everyone to
be outdoors on the road.
We'll see a little bit more
about why people are on the
road.
There's also the very important
issue that begins in these early
chapters already of light and
visibility;
being able to discern objects
and make them out,
which leaves disputes between
the two protagonists about the
nature of what they see.
If you have been to Spain and
to Castile you know that the air
is clear.
It is hot and dry,
and the visibility is very,
very good.
This first inn is crucial
because it sets up one of the
most important places where the
action will develop.
Inns, as you will soon
discover, are way stations where
all sorts of meetings take place
and hilarious scenes develop.
The Quixote follows the
loose structure of the adventure
book,
like the romances of chivalry
that it parodies,
but also like the picaresque,
so it needs these inns as way
points where characters from
various origins and classes
meet.
The inn can provide a kind of
archaeology of society,
a moveable home for characters
away from home--
What I mean by an archaeology
of society is that you see at
the same time,
as you make a cut on the earth
to study the various layers,
here you see various layers of
social classes all present at
the same time in the inn.
This is where the inn provides
what I call an archaeology of
society--
It is at the inn that we
encounter for the first time Don
Quixote's ability to transform
crass reality into literary
illusion--
although he has done some of
that in naming,
of course, his horse--a process
that is highlighted by the fact
that he is confronted with the
extreme of crassness.
No ordinary women does he turn
into damsels,
but whores;
not ordinary travelers but
swine herders:
the lowest of the
lowest--people who dealt with
pigs who are the lowest of the
lowest.
There is a grotesque contrast
between the innkeeper,
the whores, and the knighting
ceremony, for instance.
It's a clash of extremes.
Is there an element ennoblement
in Don Quixote's dogged
perception of the ugly as
beautiful?
Is this one of the reasons the
book has endured,
one's desire to ennoble reality
with one's will?
Do we begin to glimpse here in
the madness a mission to force
on to reality his perception of
it?
But also notice that because he
treats the whores with
deference, they are kind to him,
as is the innkeeper.
It is a constant in Cervantes'
work that lower class people,
even criminals can be kind in
given situations.
There is no class determinism
in Cervantes making criminals
evil, quite the contrary.
His overall,
Cervantes' overall vision of
humankind is a positive one;
no one is completely evil in
Cervantes.
In this, he is very different
from Shakespeare and his somber
conception of the human,
if we are going to believe my
very dear friend Harold Bloom
and his version of Shakespeare,
in Shakespeare:
the Invention of the Human.
Cervantes' view of humanity is
not as somber and you will
discover this as you read the
book.
It is also at the inn,
however, that Don Quixote is
turned for the first time into
an object of amusement.
The innkeeper plays along to
have something to laugh at that
night.
Are not the innkeeper and the
other guests in need of
amusement like the 'idle reader'
that Cervantes addresses?
Here is another level at which
Don Quixote is going to
provide amusement.
The ceremony of the knighting
of Don Quixote is a parody of
those in the books of chivalry,
in the romances of chivalry,
but do we not begin to notice
in this scene a certain degree
of cruelty towards Don Quixote
and on the part of other
characters and of Cervantes
himself?
This is something that Jorge
Luis Borges, the great Argentine
writer, has remarked upon.
There's certain cruelness
sometimes in the way that
Cervantes portrays his
characters.
There is a hint that trying to
do the good can be ridiculous,
and that no good deed goes
unpunished as it were.
But this is so chiefly,
I think, because Don Quixote is
a living anachronism,
he has conceptions of justice
that are outmoded.
Now, in the original,
the contrast between Don
Quixote and the other characters
is achieved by means of the
manners of speech and
dialectical contrasts--
We will see that in a minute in
his fight with the Basque,
I call him, Jarvis calls him
something else and we'll get
into that in a minute--
Don Quixote's speech turns to
the archaic.
When he speaks about matters of
chivalry he uses archaic words
drawn from the romances of
chivalry.
This is a very important part
of Cervantes' achievement that
is lost in the translation,
but that the English reader can
gage,
that is, the differentiation
between the characters or among
the characters by the way they
speak.
You can gage it by thinking of
a novel that was very much
influenced by Cervantes,
The Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn.
Speech marks the characters by
providing their social station
and even region of origin--
We will see that in a minute--I
read The Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn as a child
in Spanish and,
of course, they didn't
translate into the Spanish the
dialect differences between Jim
and Huck and so forth.
I still liked the novel very
much,
and then, when I read it once I
had learned English in college,
I was astonished,
it was like another book,
and I had a great deal of
difficulty understanding Jim's
speech.
This is prevalent in the
Quixote.
It's perhaps the first novel in
which this is accomplished.
The innkeeper is himself like a
literary character and a kind of
Quixote in that he tells of his
youth,
which is a youth misspent as a
pícaro as if it
had been a romance of chivalry.
He uses the rhetoric of the
romance of chivalry to tell of
his life of petty crime and he
is a minor Don Juan who seduces
widows and stuff like that,
he says with great pride,
and he mentions the places
where he had been as if they
were great places,
and they are really the most
notorious emporia where
pícaros met in
Spain.
So he too can play Don
Quixote's rhetorical game;
he's kind of an inverted mirror
image of Don Quixote,
here.
You have to read carefully.
Cervantes is very subtle in
creating these characters,
and here we have this character
sort of mocking,
but at the same time using Don
Quixote's rhetoric to transform
his life into something
important.
So there is a kind of a
synthesis in this character
between the rhetoric of the
romances of chivalry and the
picaresque.
This is what Cervantes achieves
through this very interesting
character.
Now, the knighting is obviously
a kind of baptism.
It is a parody of similar
ceremonies in the romances of
chivalry as I've said.
It is true that it is a parody,
but in the fictitious world
that Don Quixote is creating.
It has a certain aura of
sacredness, nevertheless.
The act completes the process
of self invention that began in
the first chapter,
it legitimizes it within that
world,
with the ceremony of his being
knighted.
Of course, he's being knighted
by a ridiculous retired
pícaro in this inn
surrounded by whores and so
forth,
but nevertheless,
it has an aura of sacredness
and that he has finally achieved
knighthood.
Now, the two episodes in the
road after knighting intensify
moral issues that Don Quixote's
madness brings up.
Why does his madness bring up
these moral issues?
Because in his madness he
refuses to abide,
to recognize and to accept
social conventions.
And that way he highlights the
arbitrariness of such
conventions.
Madmen and children do that by
asking why, why,
why, why?
Or by acting as if they don't
care why,
and then bringing out that
these conventions are,
indeed, conventional,
and this is why Don Quixote
will,
once and again,
create moral crisis.
With Juan Haldudo,
Juan Haldudo is the fellow who
is flogging Andrés,
his servant,
for having, according to him,
for having stolen from him some
of his animals.
With Juan Haldudo,
Don Quixote trusts in a kind of
honesty that does not exist
anymore, or perhaps never
existed, except in the books of
chivalry.
His intervention makes matters
worse, as we know.
This is the first of several
episodes in which the reader
seems to be invited to judge.
Who is right?
There are hints that
Andrés may very well be a
rogue,
a pícaro,
and that he may have,
indeed, stolen from his master,
in which case,
according to the laws of the
land, Haldudo had every right to
flog him.
In fact, when Andrés
appears later on--
and he will reappear--he is on
his way to Seville,
that's a telltale sign because
Seville was the center of
picaresque life.
Now, think of Seville as being
a very,
very important port in Spain in
because it was through Seville--
read your Elliot--that Spain
communicated with its overseas
empire.
Everything came in through
Seville, which is up the
Guadalquivir River,
so it's protected in that
sense.
So Seville was a teaming port
and ports are always full of
corruption,
and the like,
because of all of the exchange
of goods and the various peoples
who are there.
So Seville was known for being
the center of picaresque life.
So this details,
Cervantes throws in there,
when Andrés appears
later and he's going to Seville,
you say, uh-oh,
this is a pícaro,
so he may have been guilty when
Haldudo whips him.
Don Quixote is applying justice
that is anachronistic,
because by this time Spain had
a very well developed and
thorough criminal justice
system,
very thorough and very well
developed.
All of these matters found
their way--;-it was a litigious
society, almost as much as the
United States is a litigious
society nowadays.
So the way that he intervenes
is totally anachronistic.
Now, with the Toledo merchants
the conflict takes on a more
philosophical even doctrinaire
tact, even though it is a
hilarious episode.
This is where he appears before
these merchants and says that
they have to declare that
Dulcinea del Toboso is the most
beautiful lady in the world.
And at a distance he is saying
this one of them,
who is a bit of a jester,
that Cervantes interjects,
he says, "Well,
wait a minute,
couldn't you at least show some
kind of a picture or something
that we can gage this by?
Because she may have some stuff
pouring out of her eye."
And Don Quixote says,
"Nothing pours out of her
eye!"
and then he charges and
Rocinante falls,
and this is a totally hilarious
episode, but can one believe
what one cannot see?
See what is behind this episode?
What is the role of sensorial
experience in questions of
belief?
Isn't there also potentially a
socio-religious subtext here?
Is it not likely that these
merchants from Toledo are Jews
or converted Jews?
That is Jews,
who have been forced to
convert.
Then is the test to which they
are being subjected not playing
with the issue of conversion,
of forced conversion.
It also seems to allude to
fierce debates in the sixteenth
century about religious images,
which the Protestants did not
allow and the Catholics did,
and so forth.
The stakes are getting higher.
And as I explained in an
earlier lecture,
Cervantes presents his higher
stakes always in a light vane
and a very humorous episode,
but still, these issues are
there.
Now, Don Quixote,
of course, is beaten to a pulp
by one of the servants.
This is the ultimate insult and
humiliation, to be beaten by a
commoner after having been
betrayed by Rocinante.
Rocinante just cannot really
move from a trot to a gallop
without falling,
and you will see that similar
things happen in the future.
So Don Quixote is picked up by
Pedro Alonso--Notice the common
names, Cervantes gives very
common names to very common
people.
Pedro Alonso is like being
called Peter Johnson or
something like that-- So this
Pedro Alonso is one of his
neighbors.
He picks him up--and notice his
kindness not only picking up
poor Alonso Quixano as he sees
his neighbor but also waiting
until dark before going into the
village so that people will not
see Don Quixote in this
condition.
Again, it's an act of kindness
on the part of a very low class
character.
This is what I was saying
before about characters in
Cervantes no matter what their
social class being able to
perform these acts of kindness.
There are echoes of the Good
Samaritan and so forth,
and the Bible,
if you want to see biblical
echoes in the Quixote.
I have to tell you a brief
story, when a close relative of
mine was in the hospital very
ill,
and I used to go see him,
I used to spend the time
sometimes reading the
Quixote,
and I would get on the elevator
sometimes with my Quixote
like this,
and there will be ministers who
were also there to see dying
patients.
Mostly, actually,
I should say,
African-American ministers and
they would see me with the book
and would nod as if
acknowledging that I was one of
their kind.
So, now Don Quixote is madder
than ever because of the beating
he has been administered and he
begins to return home.
Returns home are always
problematic.
Presumably one is returning to
the familiar,
to the canny,
but now the house is going to
turn into a very uncanny place.
It is the house,
one must remember,
it's also the abode of the
books, it houses the books that
are the source of Don Quixote's
madness.
So it is the familiar,
the home, but also the place
where the source of his madness
is contained.
It is also the place of his
first battles,
as we learn,
where he would get up in the
middle of the night and begin
slashing with his sword and,
as we will see in a minute and
as I'm sure you read,
it is a very malleable place.
This house changes as if the
canny were also the uncanny--
I'm playing here,
the background of my commentary
here is the great essay by Freud
on the uncanny,
the unheimliche.
His theory being that the
uncanny is the canny,
the familiar,
becoming suddenly unfamiliar,
not something totally
unfamiliar, but the familiar
becoming suddenly unfamiliar and
this is what is happening here
with his house.
Houses and shelters,
inns, palaces,
and all of those are very
important in the Quixote
and I urge you to take notice of
them.
Now, either here or after the
scrutiny is where the
Quixote was going to end.
According to one of the
theories that is contained in
your Casebook,
the essay by Menéndez
Pidal--
I will talk about the end of
the scrutiny but this is a very
important point that I want to
make today to speak about that.
In any case,
this return home brings up the
issue of repetition,
which leads the philosophical
question of whether there can be
repetition and the aesthetic
problem of representation
because representing is also
always a form of repetition:
repeating something,
and the issue of representation
is at the core of the questions
about literature that Cervantes
brings up throughout the whole
book.
It also dovetails with Don
Quixote's own project to revive
the heroic age.
Can something be revived?
Can it be repeated?
The return also allows for a
fuller analysis of Don Quixote's
madness.
The housekeeper and the niece
relate adventures of Don
Quixote's prior to his first
sally.
The niece recounts how he would
read for two days and nights
straight,
without rest,
where upon he would draw his
sword and flail as in a battle
until exhausted.
That is, the return allows us
to learn more about the
etiology, the origin of Don
Quixote's madness.
The literary madness is not
sufficient for Cervantes,
and so he seems to have the
need as--
remember then I mentioned
Huarte de San Juan's book,
the doctor that I mentioned,
who wrote Examen de
ingenios, Cervantes
gives us some details about Don
Quixote's physical qualities and
all of that,
that make him prone to madness.
For instance,
his thinness,
the dryness of his skin,
a dry constitution.
In the thearious,
humors of the time,
the >
of the time made him a
candidate for the kind of
madness that he had.
This is because Cervantes,
unlike Dante,
whose Divine Comedy is
thoroughly allegorical,
Cervantes only flirts with
allegory,
but always seems to avoid it.
What I mean is,
this is not an allegorical
madman,
this is a particular madman
with a specific illness,
not an every man who can easily
be subsumed in the
"we"
at the beginning of the
Divine Comedy,
"Nel mezzo del cammin
de nostra vita..."
'nostra vita,' in the
middle of a journey of our
lives, this is,
this particular mad man.
This is why all of these
details about his life at home
are given,
his diet, and all of that,
are details Cervantes has given
to justify to his madness.
It's not just a literary
madness.
Now, the book burning and the
walling of the library will be
cures for Don Quixote's madness,
but both are also filled with
all kinds of implications.
But through both parts of the
novel, the characters will be
searching for cures for Don
Quixote.
And here, obviously,
the burning of the books and
the walling of the library are a
part of the cure:
you eliminate the source and
you eliminate the illness.
Now, the inquisition of the
library,
or the scrutiny of the library
is one of the most famous
episodes in the Quixote,
and of course one the favorite
ones of literary critics and
historians,
because it deals with books.
Again, it is conjecture that
the end of the library episode
would have been the end of the
novella of Don Quixote,
if indeed, what Cervantes
proposed to write was a long
short story about this man who
goes mad from reading too much,
etcetera.
And then, this novella would
end here, and that would have
been it.
He wrote many of those short
novellas, he published twelve of
them in 1613;
he called them Exemplary
Stories.
It is conjecture,
and you will read it in
Menéndez Pidal's essay
that this was going to be the
Quixote.
And that Cervantes took stock
of the fact that the character
and the situation had great
possibilities and continued from
then on his novel.
I'll get back to that in a
minute.
The inquiry of the library is,
of course, a satire of the
Spanish Inquisition.
This is clear.
The Spanish Inquisition also
forbid books,
picked up books,
and burnt books,
so it is a mild satire.
Here the Inquisition is
represented by the niece who's
nineteen years old,
the housekeeper,
a village priest,
a barber,
I mean, these are not exactly
high intellects,
and the inquisition's officers
were...
So, this is a satire in
Cervantes, even against menacing
institutions like the
Inquisition, is always mild.
It's always mild,
never very bitter.
Now, details that are somewhat
important about the scrutiny of
the library is that no book in
it,
in the library,
was published after 1591,
so that allows us to surmise
that the Quixote was
written after 1591.
The chapter is the bibliography
that Cervantes refused to
provide in the prologue.
Remember when his friend says,
you don't have to,
you can make it up,
well, this is the bibliography.
Of course, he couldn't have
given his bibliography in the
prologue because a bibliography
made up of romances of chivalry
is not a very authoritative
bibliography,
as it were.
It's not Aristotle,
Plato and St.
Thomas Aquinas,
but Amadís de Gaula and
so forth.
So what he is giving here are
the sources of Don Quixote's
madness and his protagonist's
literary genealogy.
This is the family background
that he refuses to provide about
Don Quixote's 'real family.'
Now, what has Don Quixote read?
Well, chivalric romances,
but also Renaissance epics,
pastoral romances and some
serious poetry.
What is missing from this
library?
Student: Classics?
Prof: Classics and
religious books.
There are no devotional books
in this library,
as one will find,
in the library of Diego de
Miranda,
a character in the second part,
who says that he has devotional
books.
Now, of course,
most American readers are
astonished that there is no
Bible,
but this is Catholic Spain,
and in Catholic countries,
we don't read the Bible.
We read devotional books or
hear the Bible in sermons
from the priests.
So, of course,
if this were a library in New
England or in Old England there
would have been a Bible,
but no Bible here at
all, but no devotional books
either.
What this means is that Alonso
Quixano is a belated humanist,
that is, a humanist that came
at the end of humanism,
like Cervantes himself,
a Christian with a weakness for
frivolous literature but not
very pious or devout.
Although, it is true,
for a humanist there are no
classics here either.
There is very little poetry,
although Don Quixote throughout
the novel seems to know a lot
about poetry,
and even composes some poetry.
There's nothing by the great
Garcilaso,
the important Petrarchean style
poet of the sixteenth century in
Spain who was a model of poets
and to whom Don Quixote alludes
all of the time.
Somehow, it is missing.
This library does not give the
whole range of Cervantes'
readings or even of Don
Quixote's reading,
what prevail are the romances
of chivalry about which I spoke
in the last class.
For Don Quixote they
represented a world of absolute
values in a fake past and place,
where there is no fissure,
no break between the
imagination,
desire and the real.
Now, the fact is that very few
romances of chivalry appeared in
Spain after 1565.
Cervantes was born in 1547;
this book appears in 1605;
the action supposedly takes
place in the 1590s.
So, in this,
Don Quixote is also a bit out
of fashion.
These romances of chivalry seem
to be all ready out of fashion,
but things move slowly,
and the fact is that many
characters in the novel appear
to have read the romances of
chivalry and to be very
conversant with the romances of
chivalry.
So, what else do we have?
Pastoral romances.
Pastoral romances were stories
of fake shepherds,
people who play the role of
shepherds from the eclogues of
antiquity involved in amorous
adventures in neo-Platonic
fashion,
going through beautiful natural
settings that corresponded to
the purity of their love,
and this, that, and the other.
They could lead to tragic
consequences,
and this is,
as you will see,
in the Marcela and
Grisóstomo episode that
is coming up very soon.
These pastoral romances,
I know, are the furthest away
from a modern sensibility.
One can imagine a modern
chivalric romance--
I mentioned,
I talked about James Bond and
the Fleming movies and all of
that--
but it's almost impossible to
think of a modern pastoral.
It's not impossible,
but very improbable.
But this is one of the roles
that Don Quixote could have
chosen to play,
and in fact,
later on in the novel he will
try to become a shepherd too.
He will think of becoming a
shepherd too.
Now, whom does Cervantes
surprisingly include among the
authors in Don Quixote's
library?
Cervantes himself!
La Galatea,
Jarvis writes,
Michael de Cervantes:
"...said the barber,
that Cervantes has been a great
friend of mine these many years
and I know that he is better
acquainted with misfortunes than
with poetry.
His book has somewhat of good
invention in it [He's talking
about Cervantes's pastoral
romance La Galatea].
He proposes something but
concludes nothing.
We must wait for the second
part which he promises,
perhaps on his amendment he may
obtain that entire part..."
So forth and so on.
So this is a wink of Cervantes
to the reader in which he's
inviting us to sort of fall in
the same error as Don Quixote,
blurring literature and reality.
This is what happens when
Cervantes, the author whose name
is imprinted on the cover of the
book appears within the fiction
of the book;
the distinction between fiction
and reality,
between fiction and reality is
blurred,
and Cervantes is intimating
that the reading of literature,
in general, can lead to such
confusion.
All of this,
as I will explain in a minute
always self referential things
are very funny,
but they have behind very
serious ideas.
Now, notice also the irony that
both the priest and the barber
are steeped in the romances of
chivalry,
too, they are readers of the
romances of chivalry.
They know them very well,
they defend some,
and the priest speaks of having
even begun to write one.
We will find more readers of
the romances of chivalry and
more potential writers of
romances of chivalry through the
novel.
And notice, the elaborate lie
that the niece comes up with to
explain the disappearance of the
library from the house.
It is as astonishing a fantasy
as Don Quixote's,
so maybe it runs in the family:
An old man riding a snake who
leaves a trail of smoke.
I hope you noticed this
marvelous passage where the
niece says--well,
the innkeeper says that it was
a devil that carted it:
"'It was not the devil'
said the niece,
on page 55, 'but an enchanter,
who came one night upon a
cloud,
after the day of your departure
[she's addressing Don Quixote]
hence,
and alighting from a serpent on
which he rode,
entered into the room;
and I know not what he did
there, but after some little
time, out he came,
flying through the roof,
and left the house full of
smoke;
and when we went to see what he
had been doing,
we saw neither books nor room;
only we very well remember,
both I and mistress housekeeper
here,
that when the old thief went
away, he said,
with a loud voice,
that, for a secret enmity he
bore to the owner of those books
and of the room,
he had done a mischief in this
house,
which should soon be manifest:
he told us also,
that he was called the sage
Muñatón.'
Fristón he meant to
say,' quoth Don Quixote."
Don Quixote,
of course, doesn't question the
reality, he just questions the
mispronunciation of the name of
the enchanter.
What does it mean that the
niece should tell this lie?
The physical disappearance of
the library walled off by the
housekeeper and the niece is an
instance of the world of reality
conspiring to increase Don
Quixote's madness,
and of the uncanny,
the familiar,
the house,
becoming unfamiliar.
He came and began looking for
the room, and running his hands
on the walls and couldn't find
the door.
It has been said that there is
a contradiction in this action
of walling off the library when
there are no longer any books in
it,
but Don Quixote does not know
this,
and also it would have been
difficult to explain to him that
the books had been burned or
given away.
They were burned.
They were his property,
so they have committed a
punishable act.
The barber, the priest,
the niece and the housekeeper
are covering their own actions
with a fiction,
a lie, embellished by the
niece's wild imagination,
which is contaminated by the
romances of chivalry themselves.
This reveals,
notice that Cervantes doesn't
tell us that she's a reader of
romances of chivalry.
We learn through this speech of
hers that she is a reader of
romances of chivalry,
and that she suggests that she
too read these romances probably
sneaking into her uncle's
library and reading them there
secretly.
You see how much Cervantes can
suggest without saying it
directly?
Now, a more significant
contradiction is that while the
library is walled off and the
books burned,
the characters continue to
speak to Don Quixote from within
the fictions of chivalry.
They both cure and make him
more insane, or they try to cure
him because they realize that he
can only be spoken to from
within his own mad world.
Claudio Guillén,
a very famous critic,
who unfortunately passed away
about a year ago,
says that:
"Don Quixote is enveloped
by a written context,
a literary genre that reminds
of chivalry which to him was
historically true,
structured by potential
adventures that await him
unforeseen,
but appropriate by virtue of
that genre."
Because after this Don Quixote
does not read another book,
he doesn't even read the book
about himself,
as the character's in Part II,
do--When you get to Part II,
one of the fun parts of Part II
is that the characters that the
protagonist encounter have read
Part I,
and they expect Don Quixote to
act according to how he acted in
Part I,
but Don Quixote has not read it.
Alas, Sancho hasn't either,
of course, because he can't
read--But Don Quixote does not
read another book after this.
Now, Sancho enters the scene,
he represents European
peasantry from time immemorial.
Sancho, by the way,
is a very common peasant type
of name--The only one I can come
up in English is 'Wilbur'.
I think that a farmer in
English would be called Wilbur.
I mean, in Snuffy Smith,
remember that comic strip?
I would imagine someone being
called Wilbur,
I don't know why,
but that's why I imagine--
Sancho is a very,
very common name,
it gives us--Chalk always
eludes me--
it gives us the last name
'Sánchez' in
Spanish,
that many of you have heard,
I'm sure.
'Sánchez'.
In fact, when it has that,
of course, you need the accent.
Spanish names,
that means, 'belonging to the
family of Sancho,' like
John-son, David-son.
The '–ez' in Spanish,
'Gonzalo' becomes
'González,' 'Rodrigo'
becomes 'Rodríguez,'
'Martín' becomes
'Martínez,' you see?
I told you were going to learn
tidbits about Spanish culture,
and there's one.
How Spanish,
not all Spanish last names,
how this common Spanish last
name, like mine,
González.
Now, so Sancho, Sánchez.
'Panza' means,
what?
Belly, gut.
It refers to his eating habits
and to his being very much in
touch with matter,
with the earth.
Now, of course,
he represents common sense in
contrast to Don Quixote's
flights of fancy and I mean
common sense,
a sense of the common people.
Whereas Don Quixote is a
voracious reader,
Sancho is illiterate.
He has in his head all of the
oral lore.
However, he expresses this
through his 'refranes' or
proverbs--
as you will see soon--proverbs
that are the source of folk
wisdom that fascinated
humanists,
by the way, because they
thought that the proverbs,
the refranes,
were a form of common
philosophy of the people,
and that that philosophy could
potentially contain as much
wisdom as regular philosophy.
There is the "Book of
Proverbs"
in the Bible,
and philosophers have used such
snippets,
like La Roche Foucauld in
France, in the seventeenth
century,
who wrote Maximes,
maxims.
"La vertu n'est ce que le
vice déguisé'.
Virtue is nothing but vice
disguised,"
said La Roche Foucauld in his
first maxim.
Nietzsche wrote such short
snippets, too,
but these are the common
people's expressions of wisdom.
Sancho will repeat them over
and over again until he drives
Don Quixote madder because of
them, he can't take it any more.
Now, in terms of literary
history, Sancho issues from the
world of comedy,
of the theater,
of the picaresque and of
Celestina.
Some who have wanted to do an
allegorical reading of the
Quixote see it,
the pair, as an allegory of
mind and body,
Don Quixote,
the mind, Sancho the body.
But the most remarkable thing
is that, with his appearance,
the novel's world becomes one
of dialogue, dialogue between
Sancho and Don Quixote.
Now, what is most significant
about Sancho--
and this will become even more
evident in Part II--
is that, without readings or
refinement,
he is nevertheless endowed with
sufficient wisdom to live and
make valuable judgment.
Common sense,
sense of the common people,
as a sufficient quality of
mind;
this is a quite modern idea
leading up to democratic and
egalitarian notions that do not
reach full flier until the
Enlightenment in the eighteenth
century,
and in philosopher's like
Rousseau.
Sancho transcends his
limitations and indeed
influences his master in his
attitudes and--
you will see--he engages in
dialogue with Don Quixote and,
although respectful,
he holds his ground because he
has sufficient wisdom to do so.
So with Sancho,
the novel seems to be complete,
the cast is complete,
and the second sally will begin
here.
And the second sally is where
the Quixote, as we know
it, really begins.
If it was going to be a short
story and Cervantes extended it
to become the Quixote,
it is here that the
Quixote as we know it
begins,
with Sancho in place.
So, in a sense,
Don Quixote is its own
source, again,
self legitimation.
Now, the adventure of the
windmills--I have a little bit
more--This is a signature
episode of the Quixote as
you know.
You have seen it everywhere,
represented everywhere.
You go to the Barajas Airport,
in Madrid,
and you will find a thousand
little trinkets that you can buy
with the windmills and Don
Quixote and so forth.
Why?
It's the first adventure where
the two characters disagree
about the nature of what is
being seen,
it is tremendously funny,
it has one of the most
tremendous,
one of the funniest lines in
the whole book for me.
When Don Quixote says,
look at those giants and he
goes on and on about the giants,
and, with a pause that a good
comic would be able to use,
Sancho says,
"What giants?"
He doesn't see any giants.
He sees windmills.
So Don Quixote charges,
and with a catastrophic result
that you know.
Now, there are other things
that are important about this
scene.
It sets the four-part structure
of most scenes that will follow.
One, Don Quixote and Sancho see
something;
two, they argue about what it
is;
three, Don Quixote takes action;
four, they discuss in the
aftermath of the adventure what
it was.
And there is that moment,
also, when Don Quixote says
something quite profound after
this adventure,
in trying to explain how the
giants became windmills.
He says: "'Peace,
friend'--[page 60]--'Peace,
friend Sancho,' answered Don
Quixote;
'for matters of war are,
of all others,
most subject to continual
mutations.'"
What Don Quixote is saying is
quite profound is that reality
is in a state of flux.
So things may appear to be
something now and be something
different a moment later.
So his interpretation is not
foolish at all.
He also alludes back to the
disappearance of his library,
I mean, these things can
happen.
Hey, if my library can
disappear, these giants can
become windmills and I could be
unseated.
Now, the next two episodes are
very interesting,
and one is the fight with what
Jarvis calls the Biscainer,
a Basque, Biscainer.
These are people from the
Basque country.
The Basque's occupy parts of
Spain and of France,
a very proud people because
they presumably were never
invaded--
First of all,
they have been there since the
beginning of time;
their language cannot be traced
back to Indo-European sources,
they don't know where it came
from.
They're there,
and the Romans couldn't take
them over,
and the Arabs couldn't take
so they're very proud of that,
and they're very proud of their
aristocratic background.
I know about this because my
family,
most of it, is Basque and
Echevarría is a Basque
name,
so even today they are a
frightening people.
There is this group called ETA,
that you may have heard,
in Spain.
It is a separatist terrorist
group that blows up things and
kills people,
and so forth,
and both the Spanish and the
French government have been
fighting them because the
Basque,
this group, want autonomy from
Spain and France,
they want their own country--So
this is the background.
This is the first of several
characters you're going to meet
in the book from regions other
than Castile.
Remember, Spain is made up of
several regions,
several cultures and languages,
and the Basque are the furthest
away from other cultures in the
Spanish peninsula because they
don't have a Roman background.
Their language has nothing to
do with Romance languages,
and hence he speaks funny,
and part of the humor in this
episode is the way he speaks
very broken Spanish,
and how he acts with a sense of
self assurance and haughtiness,
and so forth,
because he is Basque.
I am going to stop there and
read just a couple of things
from the background readings
because I want to speak about
the lost and found manuscript
and all of that in relation to
the self reflectiveness in the
novel and all of that,
and I don't want to do it at
the end when you and I are
tired.
I wanted you to consider--this
is a way of encouraging you to
read Elliot Imperial
Spain--
this contrast that Elliot sets
up here between Castile and
Aragon:
"The crown of Aragon,
therefore, with its rich and
energetic urban patriciate was
deeply influenced by its
overseas commercial interests
[mostly in the Mediterranean].
It was imbued with a
contractural concept of the
relationship between kings and
subjects which had been
effectively realized in
institutional form and it was
well experienced in the
administration of empire.
[They still are,
the Catalans are very good
businessmen].
In all of these respects it
contrasted strikingly with
medieval Castile [from which
Isabel, came,
Isabel, the queen].
Where in the early fourteenth
century the crown of Aragon was
cosmopolitan in outlook and
predominantly mercantile in its
inclinations,
contemporary Castile tended to
look inwards,
rather than outwards. [Inwards].
And was oriented less towards
trade than war.
Fundamentally,
Castile was a pastoral and
nomadic society whose habits and
attitudes had been shaped by
constant warfare,
[against the Moors],
by the protracted process of
the Reconquista,
[the re-conquest],
still awaiting completion long
after it was finished in the
crown of Aragon."
The point that I want to
suggest here is there's an echo
of this nomadic war like quality
of Castile in the novel itself,
where the characters are on the
move.
Don Quixote and Sancho and all
of the other characters who are
on the move.
This is a reflection of this
character of Castilian society
as Elliot describes it here.
This is just to give you an
idea of how productive the
reading of Elliot can be for
this book.
The other text that I want to
read is from Manuel
Durán's essay on the life
of Cervantes,
that is at the beginning of the
Casebook.
Now, this is just a very brief
life of Cervantes.
One cannot go much further,
even though that have been many
biographies, because there are
no documents.
There are very few documents to
be found now.
Of course, there were more,
much more documents in
Shakespeare's case,
but nothing knew has been
found.
And I think that what is
important, two things are
important in what Durán
says here.
One, he suggests more than says
it,
Cervantes, I think I've
mentioned this before,
belongs to the first generation
of writers who are professional
writers.
Before you had aristocrats and
you had the clergy,
who could write because they
had the leisure time to do it.
They were idle readers and
writers.
Not Cervantes.
Cervantes depends on
aristocrats in the old style of
the mecenas who gives you
money,
but it was very unsuccessful
that way and it was very poor,
and the publishers swindled him
out of money,
and he was poor,
and he worked,
and was in jail,
and so forth,
as you have read in that
statement.
He was in jail for his accounts
were not too clear in what he
was doing as a tax collector,
and all of that.
So these are the first
professional writers.
And the second point is even
more important,
which is about how Cervantes
was both inside and outside
Spanish society.
This is Durán speaking:
"If Cervantes's biography
teaches us anything,
it is that he was at the same
time inside and
outside the mainstream of
Spanish life.
As an insider he took part in
the Battle of Lepanto and wrote
at least two successful books,
Don Quixote and the
Exemplary Novels.
This is certainly much more
than the level of achievement of
most middle-class hidalgos of
his time.
As an outsider he was always
poor--almost to the point of
being destitute--and not
infrequently in jail;
he lacked influential friends
in a society where nothing could
be done without them and without
money;
he was often unable to protect
adequately the female members of
his family;
the influential critics and
writers of his time did not
recognize the quality of his
work;
his accomplishments as a
soldier and as a loyal member of
the Administration were
ignored--
while his every minor
transgression was punished
harshly."
This is a good point about
Cervantes, this figure who's
both inside and outside society
and hence can provide this deep
probe into that society.